the gods foretold of this day when a  champion from the mascara would be  called upon to protect man's world  you're a princess right something like  that  Diana explain yourself  his arrival is a sign man's world needs  are helpful are you truly willing to  throw away everything you are for the  mere chance of helping them it's what  you taught me it's Wonder Woman blaster  I take it deliberations are over it did  not go well you really are something  special you know that so presumptuous  it's been a long time  giganto bigger and better tea  I do so love mass destruction feeling  little though you haven't beaten me yet  poison and cyber may have declared war  on the mascara but if there's one thing  Amazon's know it's how to fight a war  and it's time to Christ  show me the path to the mascara  the way home  you just had to wait for the dramatic  entrance didn't you I thought you liked  a little drama